طبعا مشاهدينا تبعات الزلزال المدمر في
تركيا يمتدت الى الجاره اليونان والتي
تتخوف من مرحله ما بعد الكارثه اليونان
تتخوف تحديدا من موجات جديده من اللجوء
اليها ومن ثم القاره العجوز وبالتالي بدات
السنه تتحرك سريعا حيث اعلنت عن تعزيز
اجراءاتها الامنيه واللوجستيه على طول
حدودها البريه والبحريه مع تركيا بحسب
صحيفه الجارديان فقد عززت السلطات في
اثينا من قوات حرس الحدود بمئات العناصر
الاضافيه كثفت من دورياتها على طول الحدود
البريه مع تركيا اثنا تتوقع حدوث موجه
هجره جماعيه لكثير من الاشخاص الذين ليس
لديهم ماوى بسبب الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
وسوريا والذي اودى كما نعرف بحياه اكثر من
50,000 قتيل من المقرر ان تتضاعف مساحه
السياج الذي يبلغ طوله 22 ميلا يبلغ
ارتفاعه خمسه امتار بحلول نهايه هذا العام
قبل الزلزال بلغ عدد الاتراك الذين وصل
الى دول الاتحاد الاوروبي بطريقه غير
مشروعه وصل الى
8600 شخص بالتحديد خلال النصف الاول من
العام الماضي 20 22 التوقعات تشير الى ان
هذا الرقم اقل بكثير من الحقيقه فهو لا
يشمل حامل الجنسيه التركيه والذين وصلوا
الى اوروبا وبتاشيرات سفر ومتى سفيها رغم
انتهاء صلاحيات تاشيراتهم وفي اشاره الى
موقف الكتله المتشدده تجاه اللاجئين قالت
حكومه يمين الوسط اليونانيه قالت انها
ستشتري عشرات السفن الجديده لخفر السواحل
طبعا للقيام بدوريات في جزر بحر ايجه
المواجهه للساحل التركي